[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار السهلوها بابرز
العلوي
البرازيل تفوز على سويسرا في مباراه مثيره
وتتاهل للدور الثاني من نهائيات كاس
العالم
مهما كلف الثمن
في الشرق واوكرانيا تدافع بخسائر ثقيله
من مترو طهران الى عمال اصفهان الاحتجاجات
تتواصل وسلطات تفشل في ني دعم الاصلاحين
لانهائها
مع السيسي اردوغان متفائل بتطبيع العلاقات
مع مصر واتجاه الاستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
حسمت البرازيل تاهلها الى الدور السادس
عشر بعد فوزها بهدف دون مقابل امام سويسرا
ضمن منافسات المجموعه السابعه في كاس
العالم في قطر واحرز ناقصي سامبا هدف
المباراه الوحيد احرزه كاسيميرو في
الدقيقه الثالثه والثمانين لتحصد بذلك
البرازيل نقاط المباراه الثلاثه وتضمن
تاهلها للدوري القادم فيما ستؤجل خساره
سويسرا حاسم المتاهل الثاني ضمن المجموعه
للجوله الاخيره في دوري المجموعات
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الفوز ونقلي الصوره من
هناك ينضم الينا من الدوحه مفرد العربيه
ليث بزاري ليس فرحه المشجعين البرازيليين
بعد هذا الفوز مع تتفضل
[موسيقى]
قبل قليل هو الذي سجل هذا الهدف ونشاهد
هنا البرازيليون ياتون
[موسيقى]
جول
برافو عليك
[موسيقى]
جماهير البرازيليه وصلت متاخر للاسف كما
كنا قبل قليل في بعض في المداخله قبل ساعه
ونصف الساعه من الان الذين وصلوا ولكن هم
ما زالوا يحتفلوا يعني يحتفلوا همم قاموا
بالاحتفال مباشره بعد التسجيل الهدف
واستمروا بذلك في مناطق مختلفه من همم في
هذه المنطقه في فانزون هنا همم
الذي يقع في كورنيش همم واذا تكلمنا مع
هذه السيده
[موسيقى]
همم همم
افضليه اخرى لمنتخب غير همم
[موسيقى]
30 دقيقه
تمام
[ضحك]
ومنتخب المكسيك المتواجد
مع المنتخب
[تصفيق]
اللون الاصفر او البرازيل وكذلك الالوان
اللون الاصفر والاخضر طبعا سوف
تكون هناك احتفالات توت هذه الليله هنا في
الدوحه للاحتفال بالطريق البرازيلي الذي
يعني اهمنا المباراه كما قالت يحب السيدات
التي يتواجد هناك يعني الجميع هنا تشاهدين
الفرحه لا يمكن وصلها اكثر من الصوره التي
نشات خلفتها شكرا لك ليس على كل حال
سنتابع معك فرحه المنتخب البرازيلي بعد
فوزه على المنتخب السويسري ضمن ان نشرات
اللاحقه اذا من الدوحه الى البرازيل حيث
ايضا سنتابع مشاهدينا هذه المشاهد
لاحتفالات همم الجمهور البرازيلي بفوز
المنتخب الوطني
اذن مشهد الاحتفال
للبرازيليين في شوارع العاصمه بعد
الاحتفاء بعد الفوز الذي حققه منتخب
البرازيل وتاهل للدور الثاني في مباريات
اليوم حققت غانا فوزا على كوريا الجنوبيه
بثلاثه اهداف مقابل اثنين لتحجز لنفسها
فرصه كبيره في الدور السادس عشر بينما قاد
البديل لابو بكر منتخب بلاده الكاميرون
لتعويض تخلفها امام صربيا الى تعادل مثير
بثلاثه اهداف لكل منها في منافسات
المجموعه السابعه تسجيل منتخب الكاميرون
لثلاثه اهداف في مباراه واحده بكاس العالم
تعد هي الاولى لهذا المنتخب في تاريخ
مشاركته بكاس العالم
[موسيقى]
جبهه بخموت تشكل اليوم دوامه دمويه مميته
للجيش الروسي والاوكراري فبينما تقدمت في
الجنوب وحققت انتصارات مهمه على عده جبهات
تعاني القوات الاوكرانيه على جبهه باخموت
نظرا لشده الهجوم الروسيه عليها المتمثل
بتكثيف القصفين المدفعي والصاروخي
وبالمقابل يكون الرد الاوكراني الدفاعي
ايضا ثقيلا بقصف مدفعيه لا يتوقف للمواقع
الروسيه وبالتالي وقوع عدد كبيره من قتل
بين الجانبين والمشافي مزدحمه بالجرحى
لتبدو تلك الجبهه وكانها مشهد من الحرب
العالميه الاولى وفقه وصف محللين عسكريين
اصرار ومصطفى على انتزاع باخموت ياتي نظرا
لاهميتها كونها تقع على طريق رئيسي يؤدي
الى مدينتي سلوفي
والمدينتان ضمن الصناعيه التي لم تسيطر
عليها روسيا بالكامل بعد
تتوقع اوكرانيا ضربات روسيه جديده هذا
الاسبوع بعد ظهور سفينه صواريخ روسيه في
البحر الاسود وفق ما كشفته المتحدثه باسم
القيد الجنوبيه للجيش الاوكراني واكدت ان
حامله الصواريخ تحمل ثمانيه صواريخ من نوع
كاليبر البحريه الاوكرانيه كشفت ايضا انه
هناك حاليا 11 سفينه حربيه روسيه منها
حامله الصواريخ هذه في البحر الاسود قبله
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى عده سفن بحريه اخرى
في بحر ازوف والبحر الابيض المتوسط بما
مجموعه ست وتسعون راسا حربيه يمكن سحبها
الرئيس الاوكرانيينز كي كان حذر من جهته
من ان الاسبوع المقبل قد يكون صعبا مثل
الاسبوع الماضي الذي شهد قصرا روسيا تسبب
بانقطاع التيار الكهربائي في ما تنخفض
درجه الحراره تدرسيه
[موسيقى]
معنى منك
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني استاذ يوري
اسمح لي ان ابدا من باخ موت التي تحدث
عنها اليوم الاعلام الغربي بانها اشبه
باحدى مناطق الحرب العالميه الثانيه ما
الذي يحصل هناك هل فعلا هناك تقدم للقوات
الروسيه اثر هذه المعارك الطاحنه
قولي
بالفعل بالقرب من
هنالك
شديده الجيش الروسي
المعتدي يحاول ان يهاجمك ونحن ندافع عن
خطوطنا بلا شك
نحن
لم يتغير
وفي نفس الوقت
الجنود الذين
نستطيع ان نقول بان بخمته
تشهد من اشد المعارك على الخطوط الاماميه
المحورين الجنوبيه
مثل مارينكا ادفيكا وحول اوغلادار لماذا
يعني هناك ضعف من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
بهذه المحاور وهناك تقدم للقوات الروسيه
فيها
نحن
هجماتنا منذ شهري اغسطس في الحقيقه
معلومات
اليوم همم
البحريه الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن حامله
الصواريخ الروسيه والتي تتوقع يعني اثر
هذا الحشد الروسي هناك ان يكون هناك اسبوع
صعب لاوكرانيا ولهذه المنطقه المحاديه ما
الوضع هناك وهل فعلا نحن امام اسبوع صعب
اوكرانيا وعالميا نحن ندرك بان المعتدي لن
يتوقف ونحن نتوقع
وتردي الى وضاع ونحن ندرك همم
صاروخيه الجديده
حاليا
الاصلاح ونحاول استعاده الكهرباء بعد
انقطاعها الوضع افضل الان ولكن لا يعمل
المقبله قد تكون صعبه واا نحن نعرف
السفينه التي ذكرتموها في تقريركم ولا
التي تحملوا حوالي
صواريخ نحن نستعد اللي ارهابي الصواريخ
القادمه
بوتين على مواصله الحرب في اوكرانيا تقول
صحيفه وصف جون الامريكيه التي ذكرت ان
بوتين وصل لدرجه كبيره من الياس بعدما
شاهد الحرب تخرج من سيطرته وهو ما يدفعه
لمواصله القتال في اوكرانيا مهما كان
الثمن ويرى مسؤولون غربيون ان سلوك بوتن
يشير الى الارتباك المتاصل في الحرب
الروسيه وفشله في توقع ان الحرب
ستنجر الى صراع طويل والذعر المتزايد من
سلسله من الانتكاسات العسكريه ونقلت
الصحيفه عندي بلوماسين غربيين قولهم انه
في المقابل يجب ان ياخذ المسؤولون
الغربيون ما يقوله الرئيس الروسي على محمل
لشد بما في ذلك اقتراحه بانه سيكون على
استعداد لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
[موسيقى]
قذيفه يصل مداها الى 250 كيلو متر تدرس
واشنطن ارسالها الى كياب لاستمرار في
ترجيح كفتها في ظل الحرب الجاريه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا البنتاجون تلقى اقتراحا
من شركه بوينج لتزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل
دقيقه صغيره الحجم ورخيصه التكلفه يتم
تثبيتها على صواريخ متوفره بكثره المنظومه
التي اقترحتها بوينغ يطلق عليها اسم قنبله
ذات قطر صغير تطلق من الارض اي من فوهات
مدفعيه مثبته على الارض وتصيب اهداف على
بعد 150 كلم وتجمع وتجمع المنظومه بين
قنبله جيبي يو همم 39 ذات القطر الصغير
ومحرك صواريخ ام تونسي سكس وكلاهما متوفر
في مخزونات الولايات المتحده العسكريه
بكثره طريقه امداد اكياس بالزخيف همم
ذخيره ستكون
اليساسيه مع امتلاك الاخيره عددا لا باس
به من المدافع الغربيه خصوصا من طراز
هيمارس ووصول هذه الذخائر سيتيح لاوكرانيا
ضرب اهداف عسكريه روسيه حيويه كان من
الصعب الوصول اليها فضلا عن مساعدتها في
مواصله هجماتها المضاده وعن الوقت المتوقع
لتسليم هذه الذخائر الى الجيش الاكراني
كشفت رويترز الا انه يمكن ان يبدا في وقت
المبكر من ربيعه عام 2023 ما يعني بعد
اشهر القليله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلن رئيس منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيماويه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا ذاتد من خطر استخدام
اسلحه الدمر الشامل بما في ذلك الذخائر
الكيميائيه وقال ان منظمه حظر الاسلحه
الكيميائيه تواصل متابعه هذا الوضع الخطير
عن كثب وتبقى على اتصال بالممثلين
الدائمين بالاتحاد الروسي واوكرانيا
اوكرانيا بناء على طلبها تدريبا في حال
وقوع هجمات كيميائيه واكتشاف التسريبات
الكيميائيه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
في كل انحاء البلاد
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه
[موسيقى]
صعود النزيه
الجبهه الداخليه الجمعه الواحده بعد منتصف
الليل على الشاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاسواق العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد فشل النظام الايراني
بقمع الاحتجاجات المتواصله منذ اكثر من
شهرين طهران تلجا الى اقناعي زعامات
معتدله بمطالبه المحتاجين بانهاء حراكههم
ولكنها فشلت تقول صحيفه وصفت جورنال التي
اعتبرت ان الحراك هو تحدي الابرز للنظام
في تاريخه الممتد
لثلاثه واربعين سنه وفي التفاصيل كشفت
الصحيفه الامريكيه عن عجز النظام الايراني
الاستعانه بمن يوصفون بالمعتدلين من ال
الخميني ونفس جاني وحتى خاتمي بعد اقصائهم
في السنوات الاخيره تمهيدا لخلافه ونقلت
عنه طالعين لم تسمهم ان الامين العام
للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي شمخاني
سال ممثلين الاسرتين ان يخاطبوا المحتاجين
ويطالبوهم بوقفه حراقهم واعيدا بتخفيف
القيود الاجتماعيه في حال توقف الحراك لكن
هؤلاء رفضوا الاستجابه النظام الايراني
يواجهها ايضا انتقادات من داخل البرلمان
حيث طلب نائب ايراني بمسائله الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي ووزير داخليته على خلفيه
استخدام الذخائر الحيه ضد المحتشين بعد ما
اخذت الاضطرابات المواكبه للحركه
الاحتجاجي ابعادا جديده معا انضمام سائقي
الشاحنات الى اضراب عمال مصانع وشركات في
قطاع النفط فيما يواصل المحتاجون حركهم
باشكال مختلفه في تحدي للاجراءات الامنيه
المشدده في انحاء البلاد فلنتابع مشاهدينا
هذه الاحتجاجات من متر طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طهران
التي تعمل
تقصي الحقائق التي وافق المجلس حقوق
الانسان تابع للامم المتحده على تشكيلها
بشان الاحتجاجات التي ذهب ضحيتها نحو 450
قتيلا بينهم 63 طفلا منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
في السادسه عشر من سبتمبر الماضي وفقا
مجموعه نشطاء لحقوق الانسان في ايران
دعونا ايضا مشاهدينا نتابع بعضا من الرسوم
المعبره عن احتجاجات
[موسيقى]
في اصفهان نفذ اكثر من 4000 عامل في قطاع
الحديد والصلب اضرابا عن العمل دعونا
نتابع هذه المشاهد
[تصفيق]
معنا من لها هاي على الحيدري الباحث في
الشان الايراني استاذ علي يعني بعد اقصاء
الاصلاحين منذ العام 2009 وبعد معروف
بالثوره الخضراء حتى اليوم عن الحياه
السياسيه تقريبا جميع القيادات تحت ما
يعرف بالاقامه الجبريه اليوم الاستعانه
النظام بهم هل هي مؤشر على جديه يعني وصول
الاحتجاجات الى عمق واطراف النظام وهل
يجدي هذا يعني شو اليهم
تحياتي لك
للمشاهدين طبعا هذا الشيء اللي يندعي
يدعيه كثير من
الناظرين الحاليه لكن في كلام اخير لخامه
نهائي قائد الثوره هو رد على رسالته خاتمي
الذي خاتمي طلبه
يستجيب لمطالب المتخذين وكذلك ان يحل
مشاكل مع امريكا لكن رد عليه خامني بصريح
العباره وقال منهم ال- ال- المنتفضين همم
جماهيرهم من يعني جاءوا في جنازه سليمان
هؤلاء هم في الواقع الجماهير الثوره كذلك
همم
جواب خاتمي ان ااه امريكا تريد من عندنا
الخضوع في الواقع خامني همم رسم همم خطوطه
الحمراء ولن يتنازل عن هذه الخطوط لهذا
همم
استجاب لن يستجيب لمطالبات ال- ال-
الجماهير بل حاول ان يستدرج ال- ال-
الاصلاحين منهم خاتمي ومنهم اوائل همم
القاده مثل عائله راسين جاني وعائله
الخميني كي يقف مع في معارضه همم
المطالبات لهذا همم من المستعد همم
او السلطه بشكل عام تستجيب ليه المطالبات
المنتظرين همم
الاصلاحين واحكام قبضه المتشددين على
السلطه وتحديدا مكتب القائد قائد الثوره
او ما يعرف همم يعني خليفه المرشد على كل
النظام حول كل الحياه السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في طهران وفي ايران الى شيء
مختلف اليوم يعني دور الاصلاحين هل يمكن
ان يكون لهم دور بهذه التظاهرات ولو خفي
وهل ممكن ان يعني ينشط اكثر في المرحله
المقبله مع استمرار التظاهرات
سيدتي في عام 2017 عندما انتفض الايرانيون
همم رفعوا شعار لا للاسود ولا للاصلاح
كذلك في انتفاضه 2019 همم عندما همم رفع
النظام سعر الوعود همم كذلك رفعوا
المنتفضين هذا الشعور بل وزادوا عن
شعاراتهم الموتور حاليا كذلك في الانتفاضه
الحاليه نرى ان همم
المنتفضين يرفعون نفس الشعارات بل واشتازه
اصلا النظام وبيت خانه نهائي واصبح الموت
هو سيد الموقف في شارع الايراني لهذا همم
حضور الاصلاحين او همم التمسك بهم في همم
عمليه هدوء الشارع اعتقد لن يجد ان خاصه
وان هذه لا ايات رايات الاصلاح والاصول
همم هي من صنيعه خامنه والتيار الان
المتشدد في ايران لهذا همم المنتفضين همم
او الثوري مثل ما يقول البعض همم لن
يقبلوا بهذه الثنائي بل هو لن يقبلوا باصل
النظام وشعارات والحضور حضور كافه الفئات
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه وكذلك الشعوب يبين
همم تصريح العباره بان ان ان
حقهم حتى لو كانوا صنيعه النظام الا ان
وصول الصوت الاحتجاجي لشراء محسوبه على
النظام هو شيء همم يعني اساسا وليس تفصيل
شكرا لك استاذ علي الحيدري الباحث في
الشان الايراني حدثنا من لها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل ساشير الى هذه
العوازل التي وردت الان واشنطن تستخدم خطا
الاتصالات مع موسكو لاول مره للاحتجاج على
ضرب البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا واليوم
ماسك ينتقد شركه ابل بعد ما علقت
اعلاناتها في تويتر ويتهامها الضنيا بانها
ضد حريه التعبير اذا هذا كان تصريح ماسك
بعد ما هددت كل من اندرويد
وابل همم بايقاف تعاملاتها او بيوقف همم
تويتر من همم وجوده على التطبيقات شو
بالعوده الى السياقه التاسعه اصدر رئيس
مجلس السياسه السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
قرارا لتجميد نشاط النقابات والاتحادات
المهنيه والاتحاد العام لاصحاب العمل
واعلن مجلس السياده في بيان تشكيل لجنه
لتكوين
لشان تسيير اعمال النقابات والاتحادات
المهنيه والاتحاد اصحاب العمل القرار
تحديد وحصل ارصده وحسابات النقابات داخل
وخارج السودان ووضعها تحت السيطره
اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه مقتل تسعه اشخاص
بينهم ثمانيه مدنيين في هجوم لحركه شباب
الصوماليه على فندق في العاصمه واضافه
الشرطه انها نجحت في تحرير 60 رهينه
احتجزهم مسلحون من حركه الشباب مشيره الى
ان عمليه تمشيط الفندق قدم تحت
الغت حركه طالبان في باكستان العمل باتفاق
وقف اطلاق نار مع الحكومه الذي تم التوصل
اليه في يونيو الماضي وقالت الحركه في
بيان لها انها اصدرت اوامر لها عناصرها
بشنها جمال في جميع انحاء البلاد ردا على
ملاحقات تقوم بها الحكومه الباكستانيه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
فرنسا تنتقد منصه تويتر بعهده ماسك
وتتهممها بالفشل في مواجهه الاخبار
المظلله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لم تهدا الاحداث في منطقتنا حتى يومنا هذا
واليوم قبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائعه
طالت البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده
ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالمي
كم من هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق
كل يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه
واقتصاديه اصبح ما بين سطور اكثر من
السطور
اسلوبا جديده
[موسيقى]
اربطوا الاحزمه واسترخو هذه رحله الى عالم
اخر سنمزجه فيه الافتراضي والمؤسس كلمات
معقده جدا
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره الكامله
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد قطيعه استمرت
للسنوات تعود مباحثات عوده العلاقات بين
تركيا ومصر الى الواجهه من جديد رويترز
كشفت عن مصادر تركيا
ان من البلدين التقينا في مصر في مصر مطلع
الاسلوب اسبوع قائله ايضا انه من المقرر
ان تبدا تركيا ومصر محادثات حول العديد من
القضايا سبق ذلك حديث للرئيس التركي
اردوغان عن ما جار بينه وبين نظيره المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي في قطر قائلا ان اللقاء
تركز على تبادل سيارات الوزراء اولا بعد
ذلك ستتوسع المحادثات واللقاءات وفقا لما
كشفه اردوغان
[موسيقى]
القدر كان لدينا اجتماع ضيق نطاق مع
الرئيس المصري واتفقنا على اجتماعات وزراء
بلدينا التي سيتم تطويرها وتوسيعها سنبدا
الاجتماعات على نطاق ضيق ومن ثم سنتبادل
الزيارات ونطورها كذلك الامر بالنسبه
لسوريا يمكن ان يحدث نفس الشيء كما حصل مع
مصر وهناك امكانيه الى عوده الامر الى
نصابها مع سوريا
اذا في تركيا لا حديث اليوم سوى العمل على
اعاده العلاقات مع مصر هذه الصوره او
مصافحه المونديال التي هي التي اعادت
القاهره وانقره الى طاوله المفاوضات وان
كانت على المستوى الدبلوماسي
والاستخباراتى مبدايا مبدا من الرئيس رجب
اردوغان ووزراء حكومته يتحدث المسؤولون
الاتراك بايجابيه عن ضروره اعاده وتصحيح
مسار العلاقات مع مصر وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود اوغلو تحدث اليوم
لامكانيه اعاده السفراء بين البلدين خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله وما بين هذه
الاشهر ستجر مباحثات طويله وشائكه وشاقه
لمناقشه قضايا عالقه بين البلدين لاسيما
ملف دعم اردوغان للاخوان كيف لا وهو الذي
طال ما رفع طباعه الاربعه باشاره الى
اشاره الاخوان المحظوره هذا الملف
بالاضافه الى ملف مرتزقه تركيا الموجودين
في ليبيا قد يستخدمها اردوغان للضغط
لتلبيه مطالبه التي اقتصرت على شرط واحد
فقط وهو تعديل مصر لموقفها من تنقيب تركيا
عن الغاز في البحر المتوسط خصوصا وان مصر
لديها تحالف قوي مع كل من اليونان وقبره
بدوره هنا الرئيس اردوغان همم فؤاد اقطاي
كشف عن سبب تغيير الموقف التركي قائلا ان
التحولات الجيوسيا الاخيره في الشرق
الاوسط ادعكست على مقاربه الدول المنطقه
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم الينا الدكتور عمرو شوبكي
المستشار في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه دكتور بين تركيا
التي تحاول اعاده صياغه سياستها الخارجيه
وبين مصر التي تسعى الى توازن اقليمي في
علاقاتها الاقليميه هل نحن امام التطبيع
كامل للعلاقات بين مصر وتركيا
مساء الخير عليك وعلى الساده المشاهدين
يعني دعينا نقول نحن على بدايات طريق
التطبيع بين البلدين يعني في كل الاحوال
همم جرى في السنوات الماضيه هو امر لم يكن
معتادا في مجال السياسه الخارجيه ومجال
للعلاقات بين الدول من الطبيعي ان تختلف
ان تختلف الدول على توجهات على همم رؤى
ومواقف قد تتعارض مصالحها ولكن من غير
المعتاد ان همم تحاول دوله ان همم تتبنى
خطاب فصيل او طيار واحد في العالم العربي
وفي مصر وهو طيارات الاسلام السياسي حتى
بدل الامر وكانه تركيه لا ترى الا همم
تختزل هذا العالم العربي وتختزل مصر بكل
تنوعاتها في الاسلام السياسي والمساله
الاخرى كانت هي المنصات التحريض وبس
الكراهيه التحريض على العنف وفي كلى
الملفين تراجعت تركيا وقدمت همم يعني
مقاربه جديده لم تعد هذه المنصات موجوده
همم اصبحت تعي بان مصر في النهايه دوله
كبيره مستقره العالم العربي به تنوعات
مختلفه وانتقلنا من هذه الحاله الاولى الى
مرحله جديده سيكون فيها النقاش حول قضايا
اتفاق ومصالح مشتركه وهناك قضايا اخرى كما
جاء في التقرير تتعلق بالملف الليبي ملف
المرتزقه التفاهم على غاز المتوسط هذه هي
ت- ت- تجعلنا نعود الى الوضع الطبيعي بين
بلدين تربطهما روابط تاريخيه وثقافيه ولا
توجد بينهما من قبل حتى مشاكل الحدود التي
توجد بين تركيا وبعض البلاد العربيه لم
تكن موجوده في مصر
ومن مصر وتركيا
التجاريه
ظلت موجوده حتى في ظل التوتر السياسي ااا
بظل يعني مشاريع تركيا ايضا اتحدث عن
المشاريع النفطيه الغازيه في الشرق في
الشرق الاوسط
وهنا هناك التحالف الثلاثي المصري
اليوناني القبرصي ايضا يعني هناك علاقات
متشابكه بهذا الملف وهناك ملف ليبيا مما
يمثل من عمق همم جيو سياسي للطرف المصري
هذين الملفين اللذين لا يعتبران تفصيل هل
همم يعني تم حلهما بكل تفاصيلهما
لعبه بالتاكيد يعني نحن يعني اعتقد تم
الان وضع مناخ صحي للتعامل مع هذين
الملفين يعني بدء التعامل مع هذه الملفين
بعد استبعاد الشوائب الاخرى التي تحدثت
عنها سابقا نحن الان امام فرصه حقيقيه
لايجاد مخرج للازمه والاصراع في ليبيا
بالتفاهم على مسار ايه سياسي لازال كما هو
معروف متعسر ولا زالت هناك خلافات
وتقديرات
للاطراف الاقليميه المختلفه حول هذا الملف
ولكن على الاقل لم يعد بالنسبه لتركيا كما
هو الحال بالنسبه هناك توجه لاقصاء طرف
حتى لو كان هناك تفضيل لطرف على حساب اخر
او تحالف مع طرف ليبي على حساب طرف اخر
لكن الجميع يعلم ان في ليبيا هناك معادله
في طرابلس هناك معادله في بني غازي هناك
في مصر ايضا هناك رئيس البرلمان والبرلمان
الليبي ولا احد يستطيع اقصاء طرف بدعم سين
على حساب صاد او هكذا هنا نحن امام فرصه
لكي تتحاور مصر مع تركيا لايجاد حل حقيقي
للازمه الليبيه الملف الغاز ان ايضا لا
اتوقع انه انه مصر اذا حدث تقارب مع تركيا
ان يكون ذلك على حساب علاقاتها باليونان
او قبرص انما يمكن ان تدخل في معادله همم
مع الاطراف الثلاثه ليكون الثلاث دول
بجانب مصر الرابحين من هذه المعادله او من
اتفاقيات التنقيب شكرا عن الغاز في
المنطقه شكرا ده دكتور عمرو الشوبك يعني
المستشار في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
في حديثه للعربيه قال وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه السعوديه عادل جبير ان المباحثات
مع اوروبا شملت سبل تعزيز التعاون بين
السعوديه ودول الاوروبيه في مواجهه
التغيير المناخي والمجالات البيئيه
وبحثنا التعاون بين الدول الاوروبيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه في مواجهه
التغير المناخي في في بحثنا ايضا كيف
علاقات التاريخيه بين الطرفين وسبل
تعزيزها وتطويرها في كل المجالات الدول
الاوروبيه تدرك اهتمام المملكه وحرس
المملكه
والمبادرات طراحتها المملكه في ما يتعلق
بمواجهه خير المنافي وفيما يتعلق بالبيئه
بشكل عام يقدرون مبادره السعوديه الخضراء
الشرق الاوسط الخضراء الذي اخترعتها
المملكه
والقمه الثانيه الذي عقدت في شرم الشيخ
مؤخرا
يا عم بالعوده الى التاسعه وبالعوده الى
احتجاجات ايران صور متداوله مشاهدينا لحرق
تمثال الخميني في احوازي ايران فلنتابع
اذا كما تابعنا صور لي حرق التمثال
الخميني في منطقه الاحواز في ايران في هذه
التظاهرات المستمره منذ اكثر من تسعه
اسابيع
هجمه الى ماسك شركه ابل بعدما علقت
اعلاناتها في تويتر واتهامها ضميا بانها
ضد حريه التعبير وطلبها بنشر اجراءات
الرقابه لحمايه عملائها وفي شان تويتر
ايضا اتهمت شركه الاتصالات الفرنسيه ارقام
جهه تنظيميه المسؤوله عن التكنولوجيا
الرقميه في البلاد ساهمت منصه تويتر
بالافتقار للشفافيه في مواجهه الاخبار
المظله واشارك اضافت في ذات الوقت ان
المنصه لم ترد على استفتاره استفسارات
الشركه بخصوص اليه مواجهه الاخبار المظله
منذ اكتمال الى ماسك على تويتر الشهر
الماضي هذا هو كانت الشركه قد طلبت تويتر
بضمان التساماته القانونيه وتاكيد التزامه
بمكافحه خطاب الكراهيه والتلاعب
[موسيقى]
ايضا في تويتر له ماسك يقول الان بان شركه
ابل هدد بحجم تطبيق تويتر من مجارها دون
ابلاغ ابلاغنا بالاسباب اذا كان هذه اخر
العواجل في موضوع التوتر بين ماسك وشركات
ابل مشاكل كثيره قطعانيها منصه تويتر بعد
قرارات الملك الجديد الى ماسك المثيره
للجدل خاصه بعد طرده حوالي نصف الموظفين
منهم مديرونك كبار ومسؤولوا الرقابه
امنيه واعطاء فنيه
[موسيقى]
الصين تستعد لارسال طاقه من جديد الى محطه
الفضاء وسط منافسه شديده مع الولايات
المتحده وكمان نشاهد في الصور بكين تجري
الاستعدادات النهائيه لارسال طاقم جديد
مؤلف من ثلاثه اشخاص الى محطه الفضاء
الصينيه وكاله الفضاء الصينيه الماهوله
قالت ان محمد
سوف تقلع من مركز
الاقمار الصناعيه الواقعه على حافه صحراء
جوبي في تمام الساعه
11:08 دقائق
المهمه ستستمر سته اشهر وستكون الاخيره في
مرحله بناء محطه الفضاء الصينيه في وقت
سابق من الشهر الجاري رست الوحده الثالثه
والاخيره للمحطه وهي واحده من الخطوات
الاخيره في اطار جهود استمرت لاكثر من 10
سنوات للحفاظ على وجود طاقم دائم في
المدارس من قرر ان يتداخل رواد الفضاء
لفتره وجيزه على متن المحطه مع الطاقه
السابقه الذي وصل في يونيو لاقامه سته
اشهر حيث يوجد في المحطه غرفه تستوعب سته
رواد فضاء في وقت واحد والمهام السابقه
الى المحطه الفضائيه استغرقت نحو 13 ساعه
من الاقلاع الى الامتحان التزامن مع هذا
الحدث اعلنت رئيسه همم قوه الفضاء بالجيش
الامريكي ان التقدم السريع في القدرات
العسكريه الصينيه يشكل خطرا اكبر على
التفوق الامريكي في الفضاء الخارجي وبكين
احرز التقدما كبيرا في تطوير تكنولوجيا
الفضاء العسكريه بما في ذلك مجالات مثل
الاتصالات عبر الاقمار الصناعيه والمركبات
الفضائيه التي يمكن اعاده استخدامها والتي
تسمح للدول بتوسيع نطاق برامجها الفضائيه
بسرعه وفق رئيسه قوه الفضاء بالجيش
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه عن
تسجيل الانفجارات في بركان منى لواء اكبر
بركان نشط عالميا في هواي لاول مره منذ 38
عاما من جانبها حضرت السلطات المدنيه من
الاقتراب من بركان مونالوا مؤكده احتوائها
لتدفقات الحمام البركانيه داخل منطقه قمه
البركان حتى لا تهدد المجتمعات والاحياء
السكنيه القريبه
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
البرازيل تفوز على سويسرا في مباراه مثيره
وتتاهل للدور الثاني من نهائيات كاس
العالم
مهما كلفت ثمن موسكو تسعى الانتزاع بخمد
في الشرق واوكرانيا تدافع بخسائر ثقيله
من مترو طهران الى عمال اصفهان الاحتجاجات
تتواصل والسلطات تفشل في نيله دعم
الاصلاحين لانهائها
بعد المصافحه مع السيسي اردوغان متفائل
بتطبيع العلاقات مع مصر واتجاه الاستئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه